[Musique]
au départ le projet était muet une
simple photo pour dénoncer la situation
et puis les actrices se sont dits qu'il
fallait faire plus qu'il fallait parler
mcguinty mythique rich or die habiter la
zone coup d'être la marque pas je me
suis dit à ce moment là qu'il fallait
faire un texte qu'on sait faire mon les
comédiennes c'est-à-dire un carnet être
un peu un miroir de la société et jouer
la société jouer tous les personnages de
la société la famille le père la mère le
patron au travail
lamoureux dans ma gloire y l'année qui
se termine a été particulièrement
violente pour les femmes en algérie le
confinement liés à la pandémie y serait
pour quelque chose
au moins un féministe et de chaque
semaine en 2020 selon un décompte
officiel en octobre
une jeune femme a été brûlée vive par
son violeur ce qui a déclenché une série
de manifestations dans la capitale
on a ensuite sorti cette vidéo est là ça
a été incroyable puisque ça a été trois
millions de vues de parade de vue en
gros dans différentes plateformes en
même pas 24 heures donc qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui avait besoin d'être
dix d'être formulée d'être articulé et
qui a pris forme je pense dans cette
vidéo et les gens ont été très touchés
doré ou les promet
mais les réalités
le problème c'est comme si on nous
reconnaissaient pas vraiment comme des
êtres humains dans la rue dans la
famille dans dans le travail il ya
quelque chose qu'avec la femme qui n'est
pas à sa place c'est à dire c'est un
quotidien de répression invisible après
la diffusion une des membres du groupe a
été violemment insulté par des hommes
dans les médias sociaux
et puis un agitateur a lancé une
réplique pour contrer leur message
il a fait une vidéo où il nous insulte
comme ça on compte pas laisser ça sous
silence mais pour l'instant on n'en
parle pas beaucoup parce qu'on attendra
que la justice fasse son travail
mais les femmes occupent pourtant de
plus en plus de place dans la société
algérienne
elles sont même majoritaires dans
certains emplois autrefois réservés aux
hommes et des loi prévoit des peines de
sévères à l'égard des abuseurs
mais elles sont peu utilisées il faut
porter plainte parce que l'impunité
c'est la porte ouverte à la barbarie qui
va devenir incontrôlable et c'est de
notre devoir d'utiliser le droit voilà
surtout qu'il y en a
[Musique]